the jurogan experience
what's the um
what's the the new dictator of north
korea you don't like kim jong-un yeah
what's his daddy name kim jong-il kum
kim jong-il okay um kim jong-il i was
having a discussion about kim jong-il
you don't like this whoever plays golf
apparently he was just he was such an
amazing man and this this is like
kim jong-il this is like in his official
documents like this is the things that
he'd done in his official
documents
that apparently when kim yong il was
born
all the birds
in north korea
started
singing in korean apparently
but i wasn't there i can't i can't
verify or deny
i was there apparently apparently birds
in north korea they can speak a dialect
maybe brooklyn birds rap i don't know
but
this is what i know that people gonna
understand
kim yong il
apparently
yeah 11 holy ones first time ever
playing golf
first time ever
i was reading this
i know white men have lost a mind if
they ever read the [ __ ] 11 holes in one
first time ever playing golf he shot 38
under 11 holes in one at the 7 700 yard
championship course at pyongyang
in the very first golf round of his life
according to north korea
state media this was in 1994 when kim
was 52 years old even more impressive
kim stood just five foot three yet he
was able to overpower a course as long
as any ever played in major championship
history who knows how good kim could
have been if he had taken up the sport
earlier
oh oh can you find can you go down and
find in 2000 this man is amazing in 2011
apparently in korea it caught in the
official documents
he created and invented the burrito in
2011 and then when i was reading that
all the rest of that [ __ ] i was okay
with
because i wasn't there
but when he claimed that he created the
[ __ ] burrito i lost it
i was like what
you in and what does it say oh this is
the videos doesn't it's not related to
the oh it's not okay just the video is
unrelated but kim jong-il invented in
this burrito
you didn't fit no damn burrito
i'm gonna eat burritos all my life
yeah when was the burrito officially
invented it's got to be hundreds of
years old came up with the burrito in
2011 before he died
before he died of a heart attack
i found the old blockbuster movie
because apparently i was having a
blockbuster night inside that movie it
was a receipt
from 1999.
on that receipt i ordered a taco supreme
which they got rid of which i'm still
mad at taco bell about that [ __ ] i'm
saying and two burritos so that's in
1999 so how the hell did he invented
2000 i was pissed i said [ __ ] kim yo ill
like
it's lying ass can you imagine being
over there and having to go along with
that though
they have to go along with everything
over there like when he died they had to
cry for days and days and days and if
you didn't cry enough they put you in
jail for six months it felt like you
weren't crying enough
they just put you in jail
that that was [ __ ] [ __ ] man imagine
growing up there how are they
how are they
measuring your tears
you have to keep crying you have to you
ever see it they're wailing like like
acting like oh
throwing it left this watch they show
the people on the streets
the people on the streets were just
wailing
there they are
look at them
they're just screaming and wailing
i just i don't know i don't want to be
drinking nothing at this time
because
see they have to do this like they have
to scream and cry
i had this lady on yonemi park
man
yeah that guy's going to jail
straight to jail they probably found him
that guy yeah you're [ __ ] buddy
three island
[Applause]
foreign sideways he's like what the [ __ ]
is going on
these one dudes are like hey man they
can arrest me you know that right
because we're not crying look how they
got old-ass cars too they're taking them
around like a 1979 lincoln
look at that car
that's ridiculous you imagine
but that's probably the best cars they
have over there like they're not
inventing cars over there right
i don't think that's an old ass [ __ ]
car
i had this lady young me park and she
escaped from north korea when she was 13
years old
made it to china
it's a terrifying story terrifying story
she was basically sold into sex slavery
so was her mother she was 13.
made her way through china and
eventually got to europe and eventually
got to south korea uh south korea
eventually got to europe and then to
america
but it's a crazy story being in south
korea and going
to perform for the troops when they were
they were still in the active
considered active zone
and the bus
the bus we were on
the street was right
you can see north korea you can see how
their fences and all their military
stuff
and the guns
were following
our
little van because it's like this street
you're going up into this to these
mountains
and the dude's like yeah they they keep
an eye on us and we keep an eye on them
it's like this is the line
and when we went to perform it was like
all these dudes
were just ball headed
dudes just like in this like yeah we in
the field like
so and in the middle of my performance
they got cut short
because they had to go back out or
something it was like but you see the
people who in the
quote quote-unquote going into an active
zone and performing and this black
lieutenant she was like thank you for
coming in she was she was like just she
was over this squad she was like real
tough lady she gave me this coin this is
a combat coin
that they talk true thing thank you but
we have to go we appreciate it that's
how she was talking just like that i
wasn't like i'm not making fun of her
voices
[Laughter]
appreciate you and
they was gone like damn and as we was
riding back they're like yo man this
[ __ ] for real and you see it's like you
see it on um
on the movies but you don't ever see the
actual
rolls of razor wire laid on the ground
and on the top and these spikes that's
up in the big-ass guns and a tower and
you can see them
like damn
and you and somebody escape they gotta
go through that type of [ __ ] imagine if
you were on like the del rio border
and you see guns like the mexicans had
guns pointed at america we got guns
pointed at them
how [ __ ] strange is that area north
korean south korea is nuts